hey what's going on everybody I'm Tyler
Posey and we're the cast of the last
summer today we're gonna be telling you
a few of our firsts my first big red
carpet was for grownups to news in New
York who's really exciting my whole
family was there
yeah probably the up-front in New York
was about six months ago yeah it was the
premiere of my first movie which is here
burgesses loser yeah yeah six six but it
was at the ArcLight Cinerama Dome on
Sunset Boulevard which is like the movie
theater lid I always go to see like the
big movies I took my sister it was like
right house place it was right before
her birthday she was like getting on
stage don't like the answers everybody
whose it was I think it was 10 it was
for a man a man and I was really really
really really nervous on the way tuned
to this red carpet I remember fellas
gonna throw up and there and I got out
it was like the same you know all these
people like pictures and it was it was
nuts it was it was crazy I didn't know
how to answer questions back then I
would just like run on these tangents
and when you were 10 yes it's a wedding
I feel like it's always such a weird
experience though Oh mine was I think I
like Iron Man one of the I'm in movies
like oh that's a dick I loved all day
and I was really tired and so I fell
asleep during to run old film festival
TIFF very first film
vanishing on 7th Street with like Hayden
Christensen attending a John Leguizamo I
mean cuz I was already kind of
performing doing music that young so the
cameras is always like first time
meeting each other yeah yeah this is my
first time meeting these guys I've met
everybody except father okay I feel like
I'm nobody
Oh first time us meeting yeah high five
we may be met break planet comicon it
yeah Jake overnight we arrived on a
Sunday night but we didn't start filming
till Tuesday so all day Monday just hung
out got to know each other we read
through the entire script all our scenes
yeah like went to the gym together went
to go get food first onset memory that
comes to mind while filming the last
first onset memory was when Bill asked
me to jump into a lake I can't swim no
it was fine we'll get you you you'll be
right by the boat so every time
literally dying to get back to the boat
I help me and everybody's laughing Wow
yeah I wouldn't laughter you know you
know that scene we did just that one
shot walking down that little alleyway
yep I think that was it I think I really
enjoyed this once I wanna we only did it
like three times - yeah almost a one
take one
[Music]
lotta cute yeah that was now Wrigley oh
we had the best time at Wrigley we spent
like 20 hours there which was pretty
incredible it was just our crew and we
were up in the scoreboard at night and
just looking at the completely empty
stadium was very surreal I gotta say
when when foster gets he gets what's
coming to him he gets the drinks off
throwing on him by all the girls so for
that was actually cuz the director Bill
Bentley his daughter was one of the
girls that threw it on and we did a
couple rehearsals sounds like a I got it
I can react and then when you get the
liquid which to this day I actually
don't know what that was like it was
just some sticky like beer like subject
Ricky was really rich and had a Corvette
I saw that but how is that yeah yeah you
should have did he get to rip around I
don't know if I was pretty respectful
yeah we were in like a title
I think assumed once first time you were
recognized in public this young girl she
just started crying and I didn't really
get it and I first asked like why are
you crying inspire me so much and it was
like you know that oh wow like you know
you never really know the impact you
have on people because it's like like we
just simply just doing what you love
like you just we just don't know every
day thing we don't think about it but
somebody out there really really
inspired by i I'll tell you a cool cool
interaction where your fan that I've had
I was actually just recently at a
convention in Washington this couple
actually proposed to us like in front of
us in front of me and Colt and they were
both dressed up like one of them was
dressed up as Jack Cade one of them was
dressed up as Archie and they legit so
congrats you guys are watching this
congratulations I can say my cuz I've
only been recognized once I'm about to
do this this movie called hush hush
which is space s it's really not their
book series yeah and the character I
play is a fallen angel called patch and
this past Christmas I was in Paris for
Christmas I'm walking around with my
brother these two French girls came up
to me they were like pitch match they
started like chasing us around Eiffel
time that's funny cuz your movies not
even out yet right that's right yes the
first show you ever bigs watched oh the
office the office was like nice yeah the
British one good
probably the walking day really have you
guys seen Friday Night Lights before
that's what I was lying
I'm Friday is it really yeah right Night
Lights I got the complete box set so I
think all the box says box set and while
hi I'm Louis of seven kids I last
sibling so my all my siblings we would
all watch all the episodes together and
then I remember the last episode I just
watch it with my mom and the first thing
you said was that's epic Shirley cry we
sit here why why I was gonna say Friday
Night Lights but I recently rewatched
Grey's Anatomy in the beginning it's not
still a fan yeah and Dexter I realize
that's a source office um probably vo
see when I was like 12
yes calling so maybe the Rugrats binge
right because at one time probably
Dexter the first celebrity you ever met
my first celebrity that I met was a
rugby player in New Zealand Sonny Bill
Williams sorry
legend that's cool he was like my idol
as kid tech ah yeah it was John see see
me cut some yeah because my grandmother
used to run a radio station in Milwaukee
and when the WWE would come in town I'd
learn French radio stations so it was a
bunch of celebrities coming in and out
of there I remember John Cena I was like
oh and I was super yeah it's
the first year that I met was Tom Hanks
my dad is an actor also and he did a TV
show with him and I was four years old
and my mom was pregnant with my brother
so she couldn't like watch him so he
took me to Florida with him and I hung
out on set with him and in Tom Hanks and
I think Ron Howard was directing the
episode of the thing he was doing so it
was like I was in video village like
this little tiny do with these canned
headphones on yeah that's really cool I
was really young but I remember meeting
Ronald Reagan I was tiny yeah I was
really young but he gave me a jelly bean
jar no way yeah it has a good one cool
yes it was a good one thanks mom and dad
I guess maybe Rosie O'Donnell okay I
when I was 13 years old my cousin and I
went to the Knicks game and it was the
first ever game when LeBron was on the
heat he was playing in Macedon Square
Garden and up on courtside were Drake
and Maxwell max was R&B singer I don't
really know who Drake was a time was
right when he was like coming out though
so I was like Maxwell so my cousin and I
was the same age and me would go up to
him and like yell match so I gotta say
man
big fan appreciate me appreciate and
then my cousin on the spot says oh yeah
name is LA and I'm like what yeah black
summer nights dream act was like oh you
were screwing these this summer job I
wash cars for it like the Apple week I
wash dishes at my mom's friends
restaurant wasn't during the summer was
just for like three years
fish pay no head office school because
she wouldn't let me use my savings from
working
I was a counselor at a basketball camp
in Massachusetts that my little brother
went I grew up riding horses and my best
friend and I had a tack trunk and a
cleaning business to talk and so a tack
trunk is basically a large wooden box
where you keep your saddle on your boots
and basically everything that gets
really dirty and smelly and we've
cleaned it out because we're very typing
all right it was actually very
therapeutic you got me to when I was on
the road I was like probably dope
something for me straight to a game I
worked at a paintball park for like two
summers in a row yeah it was cool I was
like I was referee for the coolest
that's it was really good sick that's
conv yeah it was really fun in there I
had this Jersey and it was covered in
like paint and sweat and it was smelled
awful you would have done really good
job cleaning it yeah right guys with the
cost of the last summer it's coming out
May 3rd on Netflix
make sure you go see it thanks for
watching
[Music]
you
[Music]